hubert acket nelligan à l'escroc me
nelly arcan
dire qu'un ma folie en passe de génie
des morts entre le real et eni sequana
la séquence 8e caecl au département des
surgelés les singes en dieu à pinel en
haut le coeur ou les bennes à l'opinel
on souffle qu'un
leur finale
puis tout sacrifié par l'opinion
en s'offrant fait
de mal à nous mêmes
millage cette même un jour de pluie
c'est tout juste 90 jours depuis et
puiser au fond du trou
[Musique]
tu peux essayer
bakou
le roman c'est peut être david
goudreault avec florence carré titres de
son nouvel album ce titre c'est mental
malades
or c'est ferran ce cas est il touché par
ces questions de elle même d'ailleurs la
même écrit son histoire
on connaît david goudreault notamment
pour ses romans la bête à sa mère et ta
mort à moi qui faisait d'ailleurs partie
des fonds participe d'ailleurs de listes
de lecture de françois legault dévoile
aujourd'hui le nouveau matériel en
quatrième album
cet album il a été créé pensé depuis
longtemps mais surtout créé pendant
cette pandémie avec florence carré
amelot fat louis jean cormier luce
dufault et pour soir david boudreau
alors vous aussi tout doux tout beau et
tout c'est poignant quand on entend ne
serait-ce que cette pièce elles le sont
toutes d'ailleurs vous êtes comment vous
l'avez vécu ce confinement en pleine
création
oui au fait j'ai profité de cet arrêt
forcé de la tournée de spectacles pour
me consacrer autant studio retravailler
les textes préparés à les clips pour la
sortie de l'album évidemment se demander
est-ce qu'on sort l'album dans ces
conditions là pour nous décider d'aller
de l'avant de faire un pied de nez à la
pandémie de ne pas s'empêcher de crier
we mais c'est bien pieds nus ça me
connaît les pieds nus à la vie à la
haute roblet enfin moi j'aime bien
enfin d'affaires à ma tête mais quand
même essayer de rester connecté que le
coeur à travers tout ce dont on y voit
un peu aller ce temps à l'instinct
qu'est ce que tu sens puis cet album là
a mijoté depuis assez longtemps j'avais
vraiment envie de l'envoyer dans le
monde on était allé là où on voulait
avec les chansons donc il existe
désormais l'idée de la collaboration la
collaboration c'est super important puis
c'est pratiquement tous des amis qui se
retrouvent sur cet album là beaucoup de
personne pour qui j'ai écrit moi-même
pour leur album le souffle avance car
elle oblige accord mais aussi co réalisé
que l'ami manu militari plein musiciens
aussi géniaux c'est d'abord des
rencontres versus le travail d'écrivain
ou c'est très solitaire gain de partie
avec évidemment d'éditrice mais on est
quand même beaucoup plus seul
un album ça demeure un travail d'équipé
puis rose fait influencer en cours de
route on apprend je pense
ce beaucoup quand on se lance dans un
chantier comme ça et est ce qu'on peut
vous décrire comme un multi
disciplinaire du le slam la poésie le
roman la musique
bon on peut mais on peut aussi se
simplifier la vie pitié écrivain légiste
le gist premier c'est l'écriture
toujours parfois c'est moi sur scène
parfois c'est d'autre des fois je publie
mais le geste est malade et demnate
heures commencé l'écriture c'est ce qui
te regardent de ma vie de mes intérêts
puis j'ai en musique la russie voulait
cesser les mots mais conjugué à la
musique c'est un c'est un peu différente
du roman absolument c'est là l'idée de
la rencontre justement d'aller chercher
de l'aide puis surtout d'amener mon
écriture ailleurs j'écris pas du tout de
la même façon quand c'est écrit pour
être lu quand c'est écrit pour être
entendu d'ailleurs on a fait le choix de
ne pas mettre les paroles dans le livret
parce que ce ne sont pas des textes je
vous les avez vous un bon départ à
quelque part pas l'objet d'écoutés
puissent prendre des notes alors voilà
bien qu'aucun bois alors écoutez moi il
reste que cet album-là en pleine
pandémie at il été influencé par la
pandémie parce qu écrire ccsa d'une vive
aussi confiné vous disais mais c était
influencée par la pandémie
l'effet est limité je dirais que
forcément tout le monde on est dans le
même bateau qu'on sait pas quel point
cette crise ne nous affecte vraiment ne
pas encore le recul donc probablement
que de façon très inconsciente il ya une
grande influence
personnellement j'essaie de résister à
l'envi décrire justement à chaud sur une
crise encore il ya peut-être dit à des
clins d'oeil sur son isolement tout ça
mais ce qui est clair c'est que j'avais
toujours le côté humain la détresse
humaine et ce qui me préoccupe par
rapport à la pandémie c'est les
personnes qui étaient déjà en détresse
avant la crise ne sont que davantage de
personnes isolées
celle qui comptait sur les fêtes de noël
peut-être pour voir leur famille donc
pour des pièces comme mentale malades
comme mémoire sur la période
voilà deux de mémoire justement sur
l'alzheimer sur la démence ou un meuble
la victime de trop sur des jeunes très
isolé socialement je me préoccupe de
dire tout ce que j'ai dit tantôt
j'aurais pu parler d'eux je suis de
moins en moins mais le travailleur
social jamais vous avez reçu l émission
on savait pas où on allait venu ce qu'on
a vécu 25 février
vous vouliez rêvée pour créer créer ce
projet pour des jeunes est-ce que ça va
de l'avant
c'est toujours d'actualité révoqué la
collaboration avec elie nm la fondation
chagnon peut toujours d'ailleurs écrire
dans le livre l'état du québec heure on
en parle aussi curé de publier je crois
incessamment cc heure où ces jours-ci
donc rêvée pour crépeau seas est
toujours là et je pense que plus que
jamais il faut rêverie espérer des jours
meilleurs on va se laisser avait
justement le titre mémoires avec les
fous on va cesser là dessus pour faire
un cadeau à nos téléspectateurs merci de
cet album les années bonsoir madame
messieurs on écoute la ville où la tonne
de souvenir des erreurs à perdre le
souffle s'échappe un éclat de rire
toutes les raisons de membres nommera
c'est la vie encore 10 niort et la mort
aussi
[Musique]